what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we're going to be talking
about the future of the Scarlet Witch
and to start it all off if you are
wondering about that solo project we are
still hearing that it is confirmed to be
coming a Scarlet Witch Solo movie is
still in the works over at Marvel
Studios in fact sources have said that
Marvel Studios knows the value of the
Scarlet Witch character they know the
value that the Scarlet Witch has to
Marvel Studios is IP and plan to explore
multiple takes on the character through
the lens of the Multiverse Saga meaning
variance so not only is it not over for
our main Earth 616 Scarlet Witch but it
looks like we could be getting other
variants of the Scarlet Witch as well in
which we already saw one in Multiverse
of Madness as a rumor that she could pop
up against somewhere else it is the
Multiverse Saga and we have heard that
there was one Illuminati member from the
earth 838 universe that wasn't there
that survived that is probably going to
be pretty pissed off with our Scarlet
which so there is a possible return
there for the other variant of Wanda but
we'll talk about that in just a bit
there are actually a lot of plants and
spin-offs planned for what happened in
one Division and based off of what we've
heard Marvel Studios does plan on kind
of wrapping up this whole story that one
division started eventually in the end
with the Scarlet Witch solo project so
Marvel Studios has lots of plans for the
Scarlet Witch and Scarlet Witch
characters including Vision that's right
vision is returning in some way shape or
form but will break it all down in this
video and if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest MCU news and if you
subscribe and leave a comment down below
you're automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X a PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick a winner at the end
of each month now to start everything
off if you were wondering if Wanda died
at the end of Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse Madness no she did not die
she is still alive and multiple sources
have confirmed this the biggest one of
course being Kevin feige the actual
president of Marvel Studio was in an
interview he once stated well if you
look at when the mountain is falling
there's a little red light that you can
see go off and that tells you everything
you need to know and it does it tells us
that she is indeed alive she is the
Scarlet Witch she took on the Illuminati
and had no problem with them whatsoever
she took on all of the sorcerers and
Wong and Doctor Strange and didn't
really have much problems there either
so we all know that she could survive a
mountain falling on top of her or she
could get out of it before it fell which
is what we all believe happened so we
know that but now the question is well
where is she if she escaped which we
know she did where exactly did she go
and where is she now well fortunately it
looks like we have the answer to that
thanks to an exclusive report from
thecosmiccircus.com in an article
written by Alex Perez who has a great
track record with Scoops here's what he
said here's what we've been told sources
have informed us that Wanda maximoff is
currently in a dormant State at the end
of The Witch's Road The Witch's road is
an alternate Dimension within the
borders of the known universe similar to
that of the mirror mention or the dark
dimension according to their sources
fans can expect this particular plane of
existence to be first introduced in the
upcoming Agatha coven of chaos series
followed by a Disney plus special
presentation The Witch's Road and this
would follow the conclusion of Agatha
coven of chaos and thecosmiccircus.com
has been told that this is going to
follow the werewolf By Night Special
presentation in terms of tone and loose
connectivity to the main MCU storyline
so for that particular project The
Witches wrote it's going to Loosely
connect to Agatha coven of chaos and the
Scarlet Witch herself and according to
the cosmic circus unfortunately it
sounds like the Scarlet Witch is not
going to be in Agatha coven of chaos or
the witch's Road special presentation
although they could mention the Scarlet
Witch and it sounds like they will but
she will not appear but the witch's Road
special presentation is obviously for a
very specific purpose one of course
that's going to introduce an entirely
new plane from there it'll introduce new
people to the MC to you as well there is
going to be a coven of witches there
none who have been introduced before and
apparently these events are actually
going to take place way in the past but
the real purpose of this is to
essentially set up the Scarlet Witch's
story in the MCU so we'll get Agatha
coven of chaos which is going to kind of
be about one of her kids then we'll get
the witches Road special presentation
which is reportedly where Wanda went
after the events of Multiverse of
Madness now remember the witches read
special presentation like I just said is
going to take place way in the past so
they won't see the Scarlet Witch there
at that moment however this location is
pretty significant in Marvel Comics in
fact when the Scarlet Witch goes there
in the comics she meets her mother
another Scarlet Witch they both don't
actually realize who they each are in
the beginning but by the end of the
comic story run they do they realize
that that is Wanda's mother and the
Scarlet Witch her mother realized oh
that's my daughter but these aren't the
only things building up to the Scarlet
witches solo film we also have Vision
Quest sources have stated that the
Vision Quest story is going to feature a
loose adaptation of Tom King's The
Vision comic run which features Visions
synthesoid family Virginia Viv and Vin
his wife and two kids and this is going
to be really interesting for Wanda if
she discovers what is happening one her
kids are still kind of out there kind of
being reincarnated we'll start to see
some of that in Agatha coven of chaos
and then Vision who we are assuming is
the spectral white Vision who went away
at the end of one division now has a
family of his own but in the comics his
wife Virginia her brain waves are
modeled after Wanda's so they might do
that in the MCU as well that way vision
is still kind of in love with Wanda when
he's figuring everything out he realizes
wait I modeled her after Wanda and the
other Vision gave me the memories of
everything that happened and I love her
and this could lead up to our Scarlet
Witch solo project and
thecosmiccircus.com has stated that
their sources have told us that the
premise of the film is a loose
adaptation of the 2016 Scarlet Witch
comic run with certain elements of the
Children's Crusade being thrown into the
mix to create their own MCU story now I
honestly think that this would be a
really insane and great way to kind of
conclude the story of the Scarlet Witch
not saying that she's going to be done
in the MCU after this but for her to
reunite with her family and her kids I
think this would be a pretty great way
to do this you see this is an Avenger
story in the comics and it takes place
after the House of M story so Wanda
loses her kids she goes insane she
creates the alternate reality and she
kills a few Avengers including Hawkeye
and Ant-Man but what's interesting is at
this point in time the Young Avengers
are formed in Wiccan and speed have kind
of been reincarnated and they eventually
go on to realize that they are actually
the children of Wanda the Scarlet Witch
however the Scarlet Witch does not know
this so wicked is convinced that if he
could reach their mom and show her look
where alive we are your children she
would be better again and she could
reverse everything because remember at
the end she said no more mutants so at
this point in time in the comics there
are only really kind of a handful of
mutants left so stature or Cassie Lang
the daughter of Scott Lang says that if
they could get to her maybe she could
undo everything and bring back her dad
Ant-Man Scotland who she killed and she
could also give the mutants back their
powers and this is what the Children's
Crusade is about it's an Avengers story
and this would be a really good Arc for
Wanda to have she could be reunited with
her kids she could be reunited with
vision she could have her family and
then she could try to help fight Kang
and ultimately probably help to restore
the Multiverse because we know that it
is going to essentially get destroyed
it's also pretty sad to think that she
might get her family back but then when
the Multiverse kind of gets destroyed be
separated from them once again however
this will give her really good positive
motivation to be good now she already
essentially turned back good at the end
of multiple Madness but her story isn't
completely redeemed yet but it does look
like based off of every thing that we've
heard that is truly Marvel studios's
plan to eventually come full circle and
have Wanda redeem herself there just has
to be a few things that happen in
between but luckily for us all of that
is coming with Agatha coven of chaos The
Witch's Road special and it's been said
that the Marvels the ending or possibly
the post-credit scenes are going to set
up the Young Avengers so with Wanda's
kids returning and the Young Avengers
being a project that is coming to the
MCU soon plus not to mention Vision
Quest it looks like all of the pieces
are indeed there to set up the next
Scarlet Witch's solo film which
hopefully we are going to get either in
between the Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars
or possibly even before the King Dynasty
some insiders have stated that yes they
were working on a script for the Solo
movie before the strikes it was not
complete but of course they had to stop
when the strikes happened but make no
mistakes a plan for a Scarlet Witch solo
project is in the works and it is going
to be coming to the MCU relatively soon
before the events of Avengers Secret
Wars so let us know your thoughts about
this in the comments down below does
this sound like something that would be
exciting to see for the Scarlet Witch
her overall story connecting to her
children and vision and Agatha coven of
chaos is this exciting or would you
rather have something else let us know
all your thoughts Down Below in the
comments also don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you can stay up
to date on all the latest MCU news of
course you can follow us on Instagram
and Twitter as well and as always thank
you all so much for watching woof woof